it's important to note the geolocation
isn't just about your position on a map
it's also incredibly useful for
location-aware presentation for example
for a website for a chain of stores
right in the front page you can show
what the closest store is to the users
current location and what their current
hours are this is almost certainly
exactly what the user was looking for
when they navigated to your app you
don't have to bury it under a store
locator link you can certainly do lots
of other things with geolocation to you
could use geolocation to implement a
geocaching game for example or to do
augmented reality a geolocation as many
uses that just make the user experience
better by better integrating with the
real world environment